both the iPhone 10's max and new Samsung
Galaxy S 10 are incredibly powerful
phones so powerful that they've
surpassed what even the best games naps
available on either App Store can take
advantage of so is there really a point
to run speed test comparisons anymore
who cares let's do it anyway we're gonna
throw some benchmarks in at the end but
we're gonna focus on tests that you'll
notice in real life
unlike the unrealistic RAM management
test we see all over YouTube let's start
with which phone can boot up quicker the
iPhone hits the lockscreen only slightly
quicker than the Samsung but after
unlocking them we saw that the SN was
still booting which is surprising next
let's see which one loads and plays a
YouTube video first the s10 started
playing considerably quicker and this is
actually something you'll notice in
day-to-day use we tested this multiple
times and the s10 was quicker basically
every single time next up let's load
some of the most common apps people use
like Instagram again the s10 finished
quite a bit sooner now with Facebook we
see the same result once again so far
we're really impressed with the speed of
the s10 snapchat is used pretty often so
let's test that and there you have it
there's the nail in the coffin
the Samsung is consistently loading apps
quicker than the 10s max now let's test
LTE speed both using t-mobile's
unlimited LTE network in our office
Google's internet speed test shows the s
tend to be slightly faster so let's see
what okhla speed test shows surprisingly
the tennis max got around 10 megabits
per second faster in this test so we
reran the tests and found that the SN
was now faster so we're not sure how
accurate this app really is next up
let's download some games and see which
one finishes faster starting with fruit
ninja the S 10 seems to be pending for
quite a while before it actually starts
downloading due to this the 10s max
finishes quite a bit sooner now
downloading toon blast the S 10 is doing
the same thing again and it ends up
taking quite a while longer to download
and install now let's see which phone
loads webpages quicker in the first run
the s 10 was a good amount quicker to
load this is something you'll experience
every day so we're pretty impressed
surprisingly on this
second run the tennis max loaded the
images quicker even though it seemed to
start loading a bit later
loading Apple comm is quicker on the s10
same with loading the iPhone 10 our
product page and the 10s product page as
well overall the S 10 loads webpage is
noticeably quicker now let's see which
phone loads games faster starting with
everyone's favorite fortnight
surprisingly the iPhone tennis max
finished 16 seconds sooner than the s 10
which will easily make a difference for
gamers let's try some smaller games like
clash Royale
both phones loaded this one at basically
the exact same time now in clash of
clans the s10 finish quicker but not
much at all so you won't really notice
the difference in the real world we also
decided to test camera shutter lag and
there's a considerable amount of lag
while using the s10 which is pretty
unfortunate since the tennis max snaps a
photo instantly this may be a big deal
for some and that's definitely me now
let's finish off with some benchmarks
starting with Geekbench 4 there's not
much of a difference in raw multi-core
power but a great difference in single
core considering that the tennis max has
half the RAM is pretty impressive in the
popular antutu graphics benchmark the SN
actually beats the tennis max by about
25,000 points which is really impressive
and into 2's html5 test the 10s max
beats out the S 10 but it doesn't match
the results we saw earlier in browser
speed finally in GFX benches famous
1080p Manhattan off screen test the
iPhone scored around 119 fps compared to
102 on the s 10 which are both great
scores overall we're really impressed
with the samsung galaxy s 10 plus it
scored very high in benchmarks and it
seems to load apps that we use in
everyday life just a little bit quicker
than the iPhone in some cases the 10s
max was quicker like loading fortnight
but that's about it either way both
phones are incredibly quick and it'll be
hard to notice a difference in real life
but from our testing the s10 is
definitely the winner here we're going
to be testing more things like the
camera's battery life and gaming
performance and fortnight so if you're
not already subscribed click that button
above to sub now thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
you
[Music]